hey I'm John Krasinski and this is the
wired autocomplete interview I'm pretty
sure three or four of them are my mom
questions alright perfect
is John Krasinski an Eagles fan
absolutely not I'm offended you even
asked I'm a Patriots fan and I'm still
not over it is John Krasinski polish yes
I am that last name is not Irish and it
is not fake is John Krasinski married to
Jenna Fischer contrary to popular belief
no I'm actually married to Emily Blunt
and I feel pretty good about is John
Krasinski related to Jane pretty sure
you mean Jane Krakowski and she's not
related to me though I get it I totally
get it
who is John Krasinski that's a great
question and a big question my identity
is something I'm still searching for so
thank you for giving me an anxiety
attack by even asking shouldn't have
thrown it so hard I'm sorry did John
Krasinski play basketball yes I did not
not great I'm actually the smallest of
my family that's true I'm 6 3 ish and my
brothers are 6 8 and 6 9 so as you can
sort of surmise I was not the best
basketball player in my family did John
Krasinski play lacrosse for one day I
don't know how this is a Google search
but I feel like you've been spying on me
since I was young but I definitely
suited up got a stick got hit once and
was like thanks for playing everybody
and I retired right down in there where
did John Krasinski go to college I was
lucky enough to go to a school that I
adore and it changed my whole life was
Brown University in Providence Rhode
Island
did John Krasinski win lip sync battle
you're damn right I did
lip sync battle is a blast and something
that I am so excited and proud of it is
the stupidest idea I ever had and the
most fun idea I ever had and in the
battle with Anna Kendrick I feel like I
won but you know officially she did how
did John Krasinski and George Clooney oh
there's more become friends
I want a radio contest it was in North
Carolina I did a movie with George he
cast me in a movie that he directed
called leather heads George has been not
only a friend but a man
and been incredible to me every step of
the way how to John Krasinski hairstyle
pretty sure that's grammatically
incorrect but that's okay I understand
thank you this hairstyle I don't even
know what's happening right now because
I can't see it my hair just kind of does
this when you put any kind of product in
but without product it lays completely
flat it's not impressive how did John
Krasinski become famous I don't know if
this is an aggressive question I was on
a show called the office and I literally
became famous overnight one day I was a
waiter and then the next day I was Jim
from the office it has been the greatest
honor of my life to be able to have that
crazy opportunity so I appreciate is
John Krasinski related to Richard Nixon
boy I wish I can make a joke about that
but I'm just frightened I don't know
where you're coming from on that and I'm
nervous to ask you but if you want to
elaborate later we will never meet does
John Krasinski friends with Rainn Wilson
yes luckily everybody on the office is
great friends I remember somebody asking
me you know what season did you guys
start hating each other and I said never
truly to the last day there were more
than friends their family we don't see
each other as much as we would like to
you but yes absolutely yes
is John Krasinski's smart judging from
this interview no I'm not like smartest
but I feel like I'm smart enough to be
sitting here answering Google is John
Krasinski in Bojack horseman yes I am I
played Secretariat is John Krasinski
able to open this by himself is John
Krasinski Chuck nope I'm not I guess we
look alike I think Zac's very handsome
so I'll take it as a is a very nice
compliment so thank you what color are
John Krasinski's come on I it's hazel
and that is my daughter's name when
she's four years old and I said my eyes
are hazel that's your name she's like I
don't get it and I don't know if I get
it but it was purposeful what happened
at John Krasinski's yard sale Jimmy
Kimmel had a yard sale prank on me where
he put all my stuff out on the lawn I
really thought he was selling all my
stuff and I kind of blew a gasket and I
woke up six weeks later and I'm I'm fine
I'm fine now thank you for asking what
movie did John Krasinski direct most
recently the movie a quiet place
really excited about not only
career-wise is something different it's
a genre movie and it's really fun but
this is actually a love letter to my
kids this movie what got me into the
idea of directing it was not the scares
it was the idea of family and what would
you really do to protect your kids so
this movie I'm really really proud of
and if you want to check it out that
would be awesome
what has John Krasinski been in I've
been in a bunch of stuff first and
foremost I was in a show called the
office the American version of the
office big difference there let's be
honest there's a lot of people that are
having that debate right now I actually
wanted to join the u.s. show because of
the UK show it was my favorite show ever
and I said it was so perfect that the
Americans would only screw it up and I
said that my audition and the guy I was
talking to was like I'm the guy creating
the show and will be your boss not
anymore and it turns out I got the job
thank God John Krasinski speak polish no
I can speak polish words that are
related to food I should learn I've gone
visited Poland and had the best time
ever if you haven't gone
it's pretty amazing craic I was one of
the best cities in the world so check it
out this is sponsored by Krakow
can John Krasinski sing 1000% no and I
would prove it to you right now but it
would become an Internet viral sensation
all member when John lost everything in
his career that's what would happen if I
sang for you my wife can sing so at
least someone can in my family last one
I think there's 40 more ok great where
is John Krasinski from a town outside of
Boston Massachusetts called Newton my
parents still live there where is John
Krasinski right now I am in the Conde
Nast Building in New York City I'll be
here for approximately in the next
minute and a half if you can get here
fast enough good luck